[Music]
all right we ready to do this we're
ready
good to see you again my friend great to
see you always a pleasure to spend time
with you we have to spend more time
yeah not recording not very good so we
have this relationship right we talk to
each other through life and then that's
followed by lots of text from you they
go and responded to so I apologize once
again for being a terrible quote you
know what I did I found the way through
what you're what going through Srimati
yeah I know just in case he's not
noticing these I know you will
well here's the thing when text texts
have now become the new email yeah and I
look at my phone and there's all these
texts I know
and once I read them if I'm not in a
place to respond in that moment I can't
mark them on read and then they just go
into the ether yeah you know I know so
it's almost better not to open them
right until you're sitting down and you
know you're gonna be able to respond no
so yeah that's why not that's why it was
honest what I said to you I said you
know we completely understand yeah I
appreciate that I have no I have no
angst you know attached to the fact that
you never answer well that's not that
comports with your your you know who you
are so but I never answer is way too
much of an overstatement well the last
time you were here which was a couple
months ago about what months ago we had
a couple conversations and then as you
were leaving Julie was here and we were
chatting and hanging out and it was only
then that you mentioned that you had
suffered a fairly tragic loss your
daughter had given birth and that child
only lives like a day and a half two
days before you know that way and we had
just spent several hours together
you were regaling me with stories and
you seemed to be completely fine
I had no idea that something like that
had just transpired in your life so I
thought that it would be instructive and
helpful to explore that to talk about
that a little bit because none of us get
out of life alive and we're all met with
loss at different times in our lives and
trying to figure out how to process our
grief and move forward in the best way
that we can through these unforeseen
tragic things that that occur you know
in all of our lives one of my great
teachers in life has been our children
our son and our daughter and in working
with this because it was Tioga
his name was born on june 13th and he
was having trouble breathing and never
really maximized his lungs and was on a
ventilator for a while and then as the
probably about 30 hours into his 36
hours of you know post-birth life he his
heart rate dropped to a place where they
were realizing that it he wasn't going
to sustain himself and so that's when
our daughter asked but they just take
him off everything and she could hold
him and really connect so that at least
she could have that experience of deeply
connecting with him for however short
his life was going to be and as I say
that our children as you know with yours
are such incredible teachers if we allow
their messaging to come through you know
our presentation of who we are as a
parent and you know so in my wife and I
talking to them and no we we changed all
of our plan
and flew into Seattle in talking to them
they're saying that they chose
celebration over tragedy so that they
could get the most out of the most
positive experience out of whatever
length of life the young child was able
to have and that's not a 24/7 event
because when you're strong and able to
make the conscious choice you choose to
navigate these challenges these tragic
challenges in the most benevolent way
possible and then you have those moments
which you and I and Julie shared in
which you feel the depth of what we call
the loss it's almost like a season in
the forest when the leaves die to the
bugs perhaps or the leaves themselves
it's a tragedy because their lifespan in
that in that way is going mm-hmm gone
but if you look at the bigger picture
you know there's years after years of
leaves coming back through the life
force of of the tree and at this point
the life force of the family so the
family loses this grandchild this child
we've got you know our children we've
got our in-laws we've got our
grandchildren we've got two beautiful
grandchildren and so what I learned a
lot from our daughter Haddie perk is
that she was choosing when she was gonna
go down right into grief and grief is
not a bad thing grief is an important
thing
and that she wasn't going to go down
into it to take the children down to
take the other two children down so she
was she was managing her emotions then
if they were choosing to go down into
the emotion of we've lost our brother
and were very sad then she would go down
in there with them and they would
explore that space and so it requires
tremendous effort yeah it's one thing to
say we choose celebration over
devastation and to kind of
intellectually try to inhabit that but
then actually to practice that is a very
different thing and that's a practice
isn't it hmm
I like the word you chose there because
what you were saying earlier is that you
know we went through two hours of you
know video recording and you know we
were we were good we were we were on
point we were not being distracted by
anything and then in that moment of
communicating about this loss then we
went into that space so I find that it's
not always by choice sometimes the
emotion will just hit you right and
that's okay I let myself go into that
and you have to feel like you're in a
safe space to go into that and so it's
that's the other side of the coin that
it's taught me make every space a safe
space in other words in other words if
I'm in front of a class and all of a
sudden it hits me you know and I've got
you know anywhere from a hundred to a
thousand people in front of me I'll go
into that space and I'll communicate
about that space because I want to make
sure that I'm practicing what I preach
so to speak you forwarded a letter to
Julie and I that your daughter wrote
Tioga which is beautiful but also heart
boom I appreciate you sharing that with
us and it kind of walks one through her
emotional you know process of trying to
deal with this birth and this loss but
what struck me about it was just her
[Music]
composure and clarity I suppose over not
necessary I think the word I was gonna
say being okay with it I mean obviously
you know I don't think that fully
describes the experience but acceptance
I guess or surrender to what actually is
and there's something really empowering
about that I think and I was very
touched by her words and those of us all
of us those of us you know there's no
exclusivity here that have been touched
by death what we recognize almost
universally assists there's no turning
it back you know death is death and it's
so final and it's so absolute that if
there's not acceptance ultimately then
there's just a lot of pain that
continues and continues and continues
and one of the things that in the
Buddhist teachings was about if you sit
with anything with any pain long enough
it will ultimately turn into joy and
that's quite clearly because if you're
sitting with this thing that is
absolutely final eventually you will
come to the acceptance using your word
the acceptance of that finality and then
you have to surrender into that
acceptance so using both of those good
words that you that you led with are
really important grieving mourning is a
physical process as well as in a mo
no process there and quantum physicists
are communicating about the touch of
gravity that when two objects no matter
how small or large they are you know
they could be star systems colliding or
they could be two people hugging what
ends up happening is that the
gravitational field be it as gentle as
it is in human beings creates a wave and
that wave and they've measured seems to
go on without an end it doesn't seem to
diminish over time and what the
spiritualists have called this over the
thousands of years is the ectoplasmic
threads that connect us and so grieving
is a process in which you're releasing
those connections to the physical form
so that you can reestablish a connection
with the soul body or with the
vibrational body whatever one wants to
call it doesn't have to be a belief in
God and all of that it's just a it's
just a get a relationship now not with
this with this small baby but get a
relationship now with this sort of
endless soul and I'll tell you ever
since Thiago came and quickly left I've
got a new buddy
you know don't all eyes I get angry I'm
not I'm not always like super Pleasant
around this friendship sometimes I'm
really upset
whether you left me here Bubba yeah no
you did not I was hoping that you were
gonna stick around and be a you know be
a pal be a co teacher bhea whatever so I
go through that and it's interesting you
bring up our daughter because she
chooses not to go through that she
channels can I ask how she's doing now
he's doing incredible that doesn't mean
that she doesn't have moments in every
day in which she has to be incredibly
sad but she's an inspiration what was
really wrenching about the letter that
she wrote was that initially it seemed
like it was going to be okay like when
the baby was first when Tiago was first
born clearly there were issues he was
blue there was you know evidence that
things were not we're not okay but the
doctor seemed like they were gonna be
able to manage this and there was no
reason to panic so that creates a sense
of hope or you know a calming effect
like okay like this is tricky right now
but it's gonna be all right and then to
have it turn and then a day later to
learn like no this is not gonna be okay
yeah no emotional roller coaster of that
a day later they moved from in the niku
which is the neonatal you know intensive
care unit into Hospice right so then you
move from trying to do everything to to
save the life into doing whatever needs
to be done to allow the life to pass and
that all happened within a 36 hour
period so you think about you know time
being an illusion if your whole life is
going to be concentrated down into 36
hours that's a that's a phenomenal
illusion so how do you make sense of all
of this faith and trust not faith in
something or trust of something but just
having the faith and trust and that this
has happened therefore it has happened
it's a little bit like that moment I'm
sure and when you hit the wall in a
and an ultra race right where you
suddenly realize that you've gone way
too far to turn back it's like you know
you've gone three-quarters of the way
across the river swimming and it's not a
good idea to turn around because you
can't make it and so in the midst of
what's going on all of this energy
there's no turning back I think what
people find in tragic challenges is a
part of themselves that didn't know
existed I think that people step up in
crises in a way that they're not
familiar with often times and then it's
a matter of being able to sustain that
really high or view of things the
doctors at one point said you know they
could sustain this life for a little bit
longer it wasn't going to be you know an
open end they were talking pretty much
you know hours not days or weeks and
that's when you know that's when our
daughter just said actually I need us to
remove all of the equipment because I
haven't had a chance to bond you know I
haven't had a chance to bond yet and
that gave the medical facility Seattle
Children's Hospital incredible facility
that gave the doctors and the nurses and
the medical assistants such a relief
because they've probably been through
many instances where if they give that
choice they know that it's not a
permanent fix but that they can sustain
the life for maybe eight maybe ten hours
more or whatever and for them to hear
that somebody was already in a mode of
acceptance
was really relieving to them the people
that were in the room said that you
could feel just the tension just just
drop yeah I would imagine most people
won't let go and just say keep you you
have to keep going you know for whatever
reason like because of denial or what
have you keep pushing forward keep
pushing forward a sliver of hope that
maybe this can change yeah I can't
imagine I cannot imagine having to
navigate something like that I've had
other friends who've endured similar
experiences and and I've seen marriages
and partnerships and families destroyed
by this kind of thing I mean yeah I
think probably I don't know what the
statistics are but I would imagine more
often than not partnerships break up
over these kinds of tragedies because
the the two people you know can't find a
way to see their CC away through the
grief in a way that keeps them connected
a new character what you're saying is
really spot-on
a new character arises in the midst of
grief because we're not out there what
do you want to do today well let's go
let's go have some grief you know that
nobody says that right let's go have
some fun is what you know most people
say and so we're accustomed to our
relationship that's based around a good
time and so when our relationships
whether they're husband and wife you
know parents and children parents
children and grandchildren these
relationships are all set in motion
around the things that we do together
and so when all of a sudden we are all
now every single one of us going through
extreme grief which is you know what we
were going what we've been going through
now there's a different person that
arises in each one of us
and we have to be very accommodating and
very accepting and very surrendering to
that new person I know that my wife and
I the grandparents are one set of the
grandparents you know we'll be going
through our day and then all of a sudden
I'll notice her she'll notice me and
we're not you know we're not in that
same energy and we've found that just by
being there for each other we don't have
to we don't have to share the emotional
moment in a likewise emotion mm-hmm but
just to be there and just to say oh
let's stop for a moment that's you know
if we're driving we'll pull over if
we're eating we'll sit you know be still
if we're in the midst of doing something
you know we'll take care of that and it
has taken and our family like many
families have been drawn even closer
together around this to witness this
through the eyes of our other two
grandchildren a five year old girl and a
named Narayan and a and a three year old
boy named Sahaj and to experience what a
five year old brain and a three year old
brain is doing with this information
because you know their mom their mom was
pregnant they you know their mom's
getting bigger and bigger and bigger
their mom's going to give birth they're
gonna have a little you know brother or
sister and you know they're all planning
in their little way how they're going to
be relating to this event and then the
event turns out like what happened they
have to adjust they have to end that's
one of the things about our daughter and
our son-in-law that is just remarkable
how they have been navigating the
three-year-old and five-year-old
emotional world
so that they can fully process their
experience yeah with the limited
capacity that they have at that time
mean I you know I would I would imagine
the best way to as a parent to help a
child of that those ages do that is on
the one hand you want to normalize life
like you know not everything stops
because of this and you want to keep
their day-to-day somewhat consistent but
on the other hand you don't want to
create an environment of denial around
what's happening either there has to be
a sensitive way of grappling with the
reality of what's occurred but doing it
in a way that that that a mind of that
age can process in a healthy way
and what they have been communicating
mmm with the children and when the
children are around is that you know we
choose to honor Tioga for the time that
he was here and what he meant to us and
what we planned on being with him now
has to be transformed into you know he's
with us in spirit he's with us in what
however one wants to relate to that a
little Sahaj they went out and they
planted a tree for tea Agha on some of
the family property on would be island
in Puget Sound and after they planted
the tree and both Narayan and Sahaj were
fully involved fully engaged in in doing
it it was kind of like on the side of a
little incline the three-year-old boy
just marches up to the top of the hill
turns around and faces everybody and
says I have a brother he died and he
walks back down the hill Wow so it's
like okay I will say that to have you
know praten you know they always say the
worst thing a parent can face is the
death of one of their children
and I will say that all around the world
with all of these parents that are
facing these things on a daily basis
because it's a big world and this
happens a lot that a child that is 36
hours old doesn't have as deep a
connection in memory it does in soul
body obviously but in memory as one that
is years old a decade old or what have
you and so the level of how one would
process grief is going to depend upon
the amount of time that one has been
engaged with this person yeah yeah I
mean what I've seen is one parent well I
mean no matter how many tools you have
in your emotional toolbox and how deep
your faith is this will test you beyond
anything you've ever experienced and
it's not uncommon for one partner to get
stuck in one phase of the grieving
process and and being capacitated and
unable to kind of move on to the next
phase whether it's victimhood or anger
or denial and you'll have another
partner who's trying to normalize this
situation look we got to move on with
our lives and that's where the split
occurs there's a there's a rift and a
cavern an emotional cavern between those
two people that over time becomes more
and more difficult to bridge and these
people end up becoming estranged from
each other and ultimately moving in
different directions and breaking up
hence the split of the family so I think
it takes a tremendous amount of presence
and consciousness and hard work and this
is just me you know imagining because
I've never this is
my own I've never had this experience
myself but the challenge of trying to
move forward and maintain that
togetherness and that connection
probably is one of the most difficult
things that a couple could ever have to
do together very well-spoken and a
really important framing of what happens
in many instances grief tragedy jams so
many different emotions up together that
often times the split the cavernous you
called it the gap between people is
because the different emotions that are
all being rushed to the surface don't
match up
usually when two people are relating
it's a bit of a dance mm-hmm where
they're not stepping on each other's
toes when all of the emotions come
screaming to the surface literally
that's when you're not doing a dance
you're collapsing and because of the
burden of this emotional experience and
what I found to be really important is a
lot of talking we were we would be
sitting in Seattle with our children and
we'd really honor each other's
perspectives and I found that as we kept
the conversation going that all of those
emotions that were being crammed into a
tiny space no room to move no room to
resolve started opening and giving space
and then you start noticing similarities
and familiarities between how you're
feeling and how somebody else is saying
they're feeling but necessarily
showing it and so a lot of the
differences start to break down and
reveal the sameness because and I would
encourage people who are going through
tragedies in their life such as this
that they really learn to unpack their
emotional sensations by sitting quietly
sitting mindfully and allowing each of
the emotional characters to have a voice
so that you can start to go through and
start to pick out okay what is what is
the voice that is going to work here
because there's a it's like a roomful of
you know it's like a what do they call
those things where politicians come and
have that in a room full of people and
they've all got an issue a caucus or
something yeah right and everybody's
yelling and everybody wants to be heard
and that's a bit like what the emotional
body is up to in these deep emotional
moments yeah my sense is that there's an
overpowering instinct to isolate though
like when you're when you're in that
much pain much like a dog that's injured
you want to go you know is the dogs
gonna climb under the bed and want to be
left alone somebody who is in that much
pain wants to separate themselves from
other people and that process of as you
explained being present with that
emotional landscape requires a very
mindful proactive grounded approach to
trying to dissect what's happening
inside your your your your heart and in
your head but I would suspect that the
experience of being in that place is one
in which there is an overpowering
you know looping of the mind where
you're just replaying some narrative
over and over and over again in a way
that's very difficult to override so
that you can get
a little bit more clarity so you can
ground yourself interesting as adults
you know we tend to sophisticate our
emotions which means that we tend to
translate them into something that is
presentable and then when an event such
as a tragedy happens all of that cover
comes off now we're afraid to show
anything because we have no idea how
it's going to turn out one of our
grandchildren said you know was feeling
really awkward one morning very early on
after this event and just started
pounding this pillow
I don't want Thiago to die I don't want
Thiago to die I don't want Thiago to die
and this went on for I don't know maybe
90 seconds I don't mean like
continuously but it was like every so
often I don't want T Agata and as we
were just sitting there we weren't
saying we weren't trying to fix it we
were just sitting there being with that
child and then and the child just sort
of sat for a moment took a deep breath
and moved on they didn't go into you
know frolic and joy but they moved on
and you know the five the five sequences
of processing death one of them is anger
another is denial and that was pretty
much kind of an expression of the two
one you know angrily expressing denial
or a request for it to be denied and the
beauty of actually seeing it right out
there in front of you in a very young
expression was very very clear because
what she was saying was exactly what I
was saying often upset
I'm angry this isn't the way that I you
know foresaw this this isn't this isn't
right this isn't you know all of these
things and I was able to work with that
information I'm not saying that I was
controlling it I was able to work with
it you know not there is no controlling
these emotions and what I was watching
her go out I thought yeah me too
yeah me too right yeah and it's just
like I mean like we all have as
particularly of life and at some point
we go and when we go you know people are
left behind and fortunately for me you
know I died when I was 20 in a hospital
and you know I had some insight some
experience as to what goes on after this
body shuts down and so I have a lot of I
have a lot of belief system and faith
and I've built a whole infrastructure
around what I see as you know the
crossover between life and death or life
in the body and life after the body so
you have some tools in that regard but
that's something that everyone has to
set up for themselves everyone has to
process it's almost like we all have to
be faced with you know a pile of lumber
and sacks of cement and okay you're
going to build a house now what yeah
that experience when you were 20 I don't
think we've ever talked about that on
the podcast can you walk us through that
yeah it was
I had an appendicitis I had a man I had
an undiagnosed appendix pain that had
gone on for a few months and then one
night the middle of the night it
ruptured and that just sets you on fire
but the appendix is in a particular
position in the body it's in a nerve
ganglia meaning a crossroads of many
nerves
and so it radiates pain all over the
place
it's the heart one of the hardest events
- for medical science to diagnose it's a
big killer in the in the third world so
to speak and so it took them 10 to 12
hours to actually decide hey whatever it
is we're gonna cut in and we believe
it's appendicitis a ruptured appendix
that's cut in and and go for it
and so by that time Sept isset II it got
some ice yeah so peritonitis sets in
after they closed me up peritonitis sets
in my my gut blows up the pressure shuts
down my vital organs and they had to
resuscitate me I was out for a minute
and 45 seconds according to their clock
for me it seemed like I was out for days
weeks months maybe even years because
there's no time without the system that
keeps track of time and I'm not pointing
at a watch and pointing at the physical
body and I had experiences with people
on the other side if you want to use
that cliche and the people on the other
side told me a whole lot about what I
was to do and what I hadn't been doing
and and the nonsense that I was going
through was of my own design and I had
better accept these realities and so it
was an incredibly valuable teaching
experience not that I would recommend it
to anyone
was it the traditional white light knife
thing or no I didn't get the good I
didn't get the good dad I got that I got
that you you stupid idiot you've been
you've been playing a role there your
whole life if you're going back and you
are going back you're gonna have to nail
it you're gonna have to go back there
and you're gonna have to exude the
strength to be truly you as opposed to
Oh everything is perfect and you're
guided by this and guide of it so maybe
I went to hell and everybody else where
the white light goes to heaven bow so
what was this message being delivered by
people you recognized was it what it was
being delivered by people I ended up
two years later than the indigenous an
indigenous tribe in the way back of the
copper canyons what's called the first
migration of Z of the Aztecs there were
two major migrations Taher Mara Terra
Mara
yeah well had that's the second
migration there was the Born to Run
mm-hmm
yeah that's the second migration which
is right on the edge of the copper kenge
copper canyons is five times more vast
than the Grand Canyon sewage and you
know dozens of dozens of dozens maybe
even hundreds of people have been lost
in there never returned and so the first
migration went way back in and they were
the ones that migrated the moment the
high priests began to do human sacrifice
because that was a major corruption that
was just a total major corruption and
the second migration was when the
conquistadores came you know the
Spaniards came into Mexico and were you
know wiping everyone out and so the
tamata are the one that are there and
the widow Kuta are the one they're in
the way back and so in the way back
there what are called undiscovered
undiscovered populations under Scott
undiscovered tribes and it was a it was
a village of about 300 people and that I
ended up getting to a couple of years
later after I had gone did you go there
consciously mindful of this experience
that you had is that what drew you to
that place or they was completely it was
in one of those moments in which you go
oh my god because so you have as people
standing in front of me that I had met
after life on the other side to use that
frame of reference and here they were
now standing in front of me and what had
taken me there I was a musician I was a
recording artist for Warner Brothers and
things were getting crazy I was one of
the guys that went through the 60s
without drugs
how dare you how dare me say they say if
you if you if you went through the 60s
you probably don't remember it well I
remember it very very well you're one of
the only ones there and so and the scene
the music scene San Francisco music
scene was getting pretty pretty tipsy
and so I decided to take a break from it
after recording some things putting them
being on the air having you know certain
the COINTELPRO work come down on me
because my work my work was anti-war and
you know they were trying to control the
anti-war messaging in the San Francisco
Bay Area and so in 1966-67
[Music]
I took a break and I went to stay with
some people in New Mexico who said we
want you to come with us to our home in
Old Mexico I thought oh cool you know a
little trip to Guadalajara or wherever
you know we'll just do so when we drive
down into Old Mexico and then we go
off-road for a couple of days and then
we go hiking for another four days
getting into the Copper Canyon is not an
easy thing we had to go through a cavern
drop down through a cavern so we're in
the pitch-black and then we come out
inside the you know deep down in the
Copper Canyon there's parts of the
Copper Canyon that has three seasons all
going on at once there'll be there'll be
hail snow on top of the mountains and
all the way down to tropical middle of
summer in the bottom so it's a it's a
remarkable place so what happened was I
met these people during that minute and
45 seconds on the other side they told
me what I had to do in life and that I
had to quit trying to be someone else
trying to be like someone else or being
held back by the fact that I couldn't
see myself being what I was trying to
imagine myself being I mean it's like
it's like the the death that you went
through when you went through from being
a lawyer to being who you
today from being an unhappy you know
lawyer to being a happy guy you know at
24 miles into a marathoner yeah but I
didn't get a visitation now maybe not in
the same exact way yeah all right so
you're starting to have this sense of
that which in certain respects I think
you could argue is what lured you down
there right so you're down in the Copper
Canyon well I'm I'm with this guy who's
he and his wife had and she wasn't with
us at that moment but he and his wife is
I had stayed with them after a concert
that I did in Albuquerque and they said
you know come on you got a break now
come onto our land we want to show you
and so they showed me this this
incredible land which I then after when
I decided to take a break from the music
and I thought I was gonna be gone two
weeks right I was gone 11 months
everybody because there's no
communication it was an undiscovered
tribe so there's nothing happening
inside and outside that world every
thought I had got off and died somewhere
yeah so the end result was that I met
the people in the flesh that I had met
before and they knew when they met me
before that I was going to ultimately
meet in so that's the kind of magic that
goes on in the indigenous world so when
you met these people and you had this
moment of recognition were they having
that same experience like were they oh
he's here mm-hmm and what they knew was
that they were going to bring me
ultimately they were going to get me to
come in person to them in person so they
had the they had the meditative capacity
to go outside their body and be out in
the non-physical zone what and I'm not
going to use any specific names just so
that we don't brand it and in the
non-physical zone we meet we have
communication I end up with
defibrillator paddles getting sucked
back into my body so I leave them so to
speak behind and then I go through my
life which is now very tenuous and I go
through my life get out of the draft go
through process
end up having a musical career taking a
break from musical career coming to
their son and daughter-in-law so to
speak going with them down into where
they actually are physically had then
four passages rites of passage you know
vision quests that they set me through
and but what it gave me when Thiago
passed it gave me a greater sense of
comfort as well as a greater sense of
discomfort because I got to come back in
and continue my journey he wasn't to do
that he wasn't able to have that where
his body gets somehow resuscitated and
he can move on and that's like what our
daughter was saying in that letter that
she wrote that in the early stages the
doctors were all feeling positive and
mm-hmm
so the one of the things that also comes
up in grief is the tenderness of life
and how intricate this physical body is
and how important what we feed it is how
we rest it is how we exercise it is how
we emote through it is how we think
within it is you know and so instead of
being kind of haphazard in life you tend
to through the process of grief become
more articulating and more accurate and
hopefully you can sustain that because
life in general is not articulate and is
not always accurate yeah I think the
flip side of the person who gets stuck
in one of those five phases is the
individual who then has moments of joy
or
moments where they forget what has
happened and they're able to be happy
and then they kind of snap back in when
they remember what has occurred and then
are then visited by guilt or shame for
them feeling happy again right like like
am I allowed to experience joy and if I
do what does that say about how I feel
about this thing that has occurred right
you just you just hit probably the most
common is that guilt shame of feeling
good about feeling bad or feeling good
instead of feeling bad or feeling bad
about feeling good feeling bad about
feeling good what was it that you said
is you you and you were correcting
yourself you said is she okay
right is she okay with this or so you
were using some kind of a word like that
and those are the those are the ways
what we have to be able to do and really
encourage ourself which is the heart
center encourage ourself core and
French's heart so when we encourage we
we bring into our heart we get some
willpower invested and to encourage
ourselves to unwrap that process feeling
good feeling guilty about feeling good
feeling bad about feeling good and then
also go take it one step further feeling
good about feeling bad I'm doing the
right thing as I'm feeling bad right and
we need to unwrap these so that we're
not caught in the whirlpool of the
emotion but we're actually navigating
we've got some kind of a vessel that we
can navigate the whirlpool in and that's
not easy but I will tell you that what
has helped me the most in navigating the
highly emotional moments is breath
breathwork and what does that look like
it looks like becoming mindful of
breathing just all of a sudden I'm
feeling all of this emotion I'm gonna
allow myself to feel that emotion now
it's come to a time when I am I have
something that I have to do I have
something that I have to be able to
present then I will go into my breath
and I'll just start very consciously
very deeply breathing and all of a
sudden I'm not in touch with so much my
life as I'm in touch with life itself
and that suddenly lets me feel okay soul
enters the body you know soul is born in
the body soul is only able to use the
body for 36 hours or 36 days or three
and a half years or whatever it is and
then soul leaves the body or life
however one wants to relate life leaves
the body so in physics there's a rule
that is considered universal and that is
that energy can't be created or
destroyed it can only be transformed and
so as the life enters the body it's an
energy in these cells and as the life
leaves the body it's an energy that has
left these cells and that energy the
body is dead but that energy still
exists so then as I'm working with my
breath I'm connecting with that energy
and that's who Tioga is now that's I
don't believe there's anybody that can
do that better than
someone who has experienced this
firsthand and is choosing to get beyond
it in a very healthy way one of whom is
our daughter and that letter as you as
you experienced that I am she is saying
and my wife and I are choosing the same
path choosing to stay connected to Tiago
not to Thiago's body hmm yeah it's I
think the way that we culturally relate
to these kinds of things has developed
and sort of metastasized into a very
unhealthy psychological disease for lack
of a better word and I think that's a
function of the fact that in our modern
lives we have insulated ourselves from
so many of the primal rhythms yeah you
know what that that you know ancestrally
to find us as human being so
intellectually we understand yes we will
die
bad things happen etc but meanwhile I'm
in you know in my house and the air
conditionings on and I go to my job and
it's about you know just living our
lives and and we feel like those things
happen to other people or yeah I'm gonna
die but maybe I won't you know like I
don't mean you know like maybe that just
happens to other people
and we've whitewashed society to such an
extent that we we don't see we do it's
very difficult actually to be connected
to the passing of another human being
you might go to a funeral but do you see
a dead body or have you seen a dead body
in your life like I think I only have
once in my entire life and so it's
removed from your line of sight from
your field of vision completely and when
it's not present
in your day-to-day existence when it
does occur it comes as a shock or some
kind of aberration and I think that that
has created a very unhealthy
relationship to this one thing that we
cannot escape and I think it's important
like you know that was a very beautiful
story and I think it's a very healthy
relationship to a situation that you
know you certainly didn't want to have
happen but these things do happen how
can we as a culture create a healthier
relationship to the passing of our loved
ones or just death in general and I
think we have to invite it back in like
work it's such a taboo it's not even
socially polite talk about it and I
think it creates an awkwardness like in
this very situation that you're in
Outsiders don't know what to say do we
visit them do we bring a casserole what
do we say when we're there oh it's
easier to just let's just leave them
alone for now through their grieving
process because we're uncomfortable and
we don't know what the appropriate
action is to take because we don't have
experience with this - two ways of
working with this in today's world one
is hospice and another one is after
death is the wake both of which are
incredibly healthy and healing we have
an associate who is you know there are
birth doulas and she is in a category of
what's called a death doula and they
attend to the dying in Hospice and one
of the things that her task is is to get
the relatives to feel as comfortable
with whoever it is that's passing as
they were when they were living that in
by this time in hospice death is
inevitable it's not like you know we're
looking for a miracle or were you know
trying a new form of whatever medicine
but death is inevitable and what she
finds is that she can work people into
the process of let's be good with what
this person is now able to communicate
or experience right and if all they can
experience if they're no longer able to
speak or perhaps not even able to hear
the holding of hands or the telling of
stories maybe they can't speak but they
can still hear so the telling of stories
of what you remember about them in front
of them you're telling these stories and
so the process of dying has some
consciousness that is arising in these
Western industrial nations much of which
comes from the old traditions even the
indigenous traditions and for example
take that of the Judaic system of having
a wake
sometimes the Christians sometimes the
Hindus sometimes others the Buddhist
they'll have a wake after the death and
everybody will gather and yeah people
are crying people are home sometimes
wearing dark glasses because they're
embarrassed about showing how much how
swollen their eyes might be but it's a
time when people sit around they share
they share nourishment they share food
and they share conversations about do
you remember when and golly it was just
seems like it was just yesterday that we
were all with so-and-so and you know we
were doing this and doing that and sort
of sharing those aspects of a person's
life after they have passed or sharing
with the idea of Hospice so both of
these are need to have a true and a an
assertive revitalization so that we can
really start to have the experience of
someone else's experience so that even
if we have not purse
he had the experience at least we've
shared it or shared space with somebody
that has I would I would strongly
suggest by the way to because you're
right
going into isolation is very is very
instinctual and and there have been
times during this these past two or
three months I guess it's two and a half
months almost now that all I want to do
is just get in bed pull the quilts over
put my head under a pillow not on a
pillow but under a pillow and just go
black right just go black I don't wanna
I don't want to have to respond to
anybody I don't want to do anything and
sometimes I will just go off and
meditate in you know as isolated a place
as I can find but I also find that if
instead of going to that isolation if I
will take myself into a conversation
that I'm much more present you know I
pride myself in being very present in
most moments and I've found that there's
a degree of presence that even I hadn't
had before this experience and so both
isolation and conversation are healthy
but too much of one and not enough of
the other is probably not the healthiest
way of doing it yeah I think it's
completely normal and fine if you want
to get in bed and pull up pillow over
your head but if you can't get out of
bed for a month then it becomes an issue
right like I think it's it's a function
of you know accepting where you're at of
being okay with that like right now this
is what I need to do as long as you're
progressing at whatever rate through
these various phases and I think
isolation is fine as well as long as you
can break your way out of that and get
to a place where you're able to be with
other people and communicate I hope
you're looking at your visual aids I
have a visual aid
and so haha big big visual aid what you
know so here's our presence this is the
what is and here's our preference this
is the what we want it to be and so if
you think of a tree a tree has a growth
point and a tree as a center point the
growth point is the area of the tree
that's going to be giving new birth to
growth right and we we also have a
growth point and a center point our
center point is our groundedness in what
we would call the what is and our growth
point are all of our aspirations you
know what are you going to what are you
going to achieve what are you going to
do how are you going to be etc in grief
the preferences get all distorted
because some of the preferences of I
don't want I don't want Yaga to die are
not possible to be met and so what ends
up happening is that you've got to be
able to live with the acceptance of your
preference while sitting in the presence
of your groundedness and in that way you
have to navigate what's called the
difference so it's presence preference
and difference and it's this difference
that it says we ruled by water because
it's highly emotional and what you end
up with is you end up with this if you
can do it and we're not successful as I
say 24/7 but when a tragedy is upon you
if you can sit in your presence and be
in that state of not wanting to isolate
but wanting to even if you isolate
you're just you're inside yourself and
then begin to work with your preferences
which ones of them are realistic which
ones of them are not realistic and as
each person
gets this sort of formation to work then
relationships can work so if a couple is
finding it awkward to be around each
other because of a tragic loss then that
couple each one each member of that
couple needs to come into their center
point which is if you want to physically
it's in the called the don t an inn in
chinese medicine it's that point that's
between the navel and the tail in the
end the tailbone that diagonal halfway
down so it's inside your body that's
where the true navel point is and so you
feel this gut feeling of centeredness
and you propagate it you you develop it
you nourish it that's why in awake they
would serve a lot of food so the people
could come to that place that digestive
place not only are they digesting the
food they're digesting the event and
then in the preferences in awake you're
talking about all those wonderful times
you had together and you're preferring
to remember those wonderful times while
not getting lost in that memory as if
it's an illusion but staying grounded
and so for example what we are doing in
in our family and what our daughter and
son-in-law are really instrumental and
our son to really instrumental in
guiding the family towards is that we
choose to celebrate Thiago's life in the
midst of all of the emotions that are
going to be arising in the process so I
used that just so that people could see
kind of graphically that we're not just
talking like concepts here yes so for
people that are listening and not
watching on YouTube carousing held up a
placard an enormous yeah at the at the
bottom it said presence
there was and then above that it said
preference in between is the difference
defined by water emotion turbulence
turbulence
no I get that you know and I think
that's beautiful
so harder to practice than to talk about
I would imagine much harder yeah all
right we need to wrap up this edition of
the Guru multiverse so I would just say
in wrapping that the expression called
good grief Israel that grief the
mourning process is important everyone
will go through it in their own way
there are tools that you can use to help
you through it
most importantly is communication
conversation healthy isolation mixing
that together not getting into anyone to
deviate from you know one form into a
total denial or a total you know refusal
or anger mode but to really go through
the process fully and it becomes good
grief mm-hmm so if someone's listening
to this and they're in that spot they're
navigating loss they're in their grief
and they feel stuck like I just cannot
escape this prison I'm so angry the
world has wronged me and I cannot see my
way to the other side you know what is
the you know what is the path like what
what can you say to that person and what
practices you've talked about breath
you've talked about communication but
you know what do you say to that person
a cosmic law is it for every action
there is an equal reaction so for every
circumstance there is the polarity
they're in a place
stuck this is wrong never should have
happened I'll never break out of this
right next to that is
not stuck this was not wrong even though
it was horrible something is here if you
can open up to the possibility that the
law of physics the law of the cosmos is
that for every action there's an equal
polarity an equal and opposite reaction
then that will give you a little working
space because in stuck there's no space
and you have to you have to give
yourself the the gift of finding some
amount of space that'll allow you to
make some movement knowing in some way
that the law of physics the law of the
cosmos is that the other side still
exists that will then trigger hope and
you can start to slowly work your way
out breath by breath step by step yeah
the adage that everything that shows up
is for your growth I think is true there
is an opportunity and everything for
transformation for greater
self-actualization but to deliver that
message to somebody who's in that space
is not going to be well received it's
gonna be it's not gonna be an ass not
the right thing not the thing to say
it's an fu but to deliver to them I
don't ever go look for that look on the
brighter side you know but I do go to
the place where even in talking with
myself as terrible as this is there is
other things taking place and if I can
find my way to the other things without
being in denial of what the tragedy
that's happened then I can begin to get
a segue a move
a shift hmm well I think it's a good
place to end this session thank you you
are a blessing my friend
I appreciate your message and your
compassion and your wisdom and it's
always a gift to talk to you so thank
you yeah and I just and I do want to
make clear that no matter how advanced
one might seem these kinds of situations
cut you off at the ankles and you there
is no perfect way through there is
everyone does it the way they can do it
yeah it's messy no matter what well
beautiful alright until next time mmm
peace plants namaste
Sano
[Music]